wait oh pond okay cool nice
have we been white every single game yes
oh oh it's a bird now okay so now we get
the bird
um knight
do you ever play the dutch no
josh is for black yeah it's like a
reverse bird
kind of or bird is rivers dutch
pond
oh
actually don't know i guess i'll say
pawn
so there's something have you heard of
the polar bear
like the animal polar bear or the
opening
well kind of both but it's it's a
opening named after the animal
okay i've never heard of the lp okay uh
bishop
so the polar bear is a is basically a
variation of the bird
which we couldn't do unfortunately in
this game a castle or a king
i should get banned for that uh let's do
knight
okay gotta be careful here
yeah so polar bear usually involves a
setup like this
but with like b3 bishop b2 which we
couldn't achieve
like earlier because that's what i
usually play oh really oh so you you
basically
play a polar bear unknowingly yes i've
always been a polar bear ah
okay yeah so i guess it's it's not so
well known
like the terminology with the names
um i think there's a book it's a book
written by some
icelandic gm on the polar bear
let's do knights
wait night again
nice i'll finally finally get the other
knight involved
got it so i was honestly thinking
leaving the knot on e5 and playing
knight d2
uh initially but this is fine
it's gonna get reincarnated don't worry
into what
oh no i just said the knight on e5 it's
going to get reincarnated oh
no but reincarnated is when like you die
and then you you take a different life
form
right why can't you be the same i guess
you could
yeah i never thought about it that way
night
this is getting deep conversation
yeah i'm already kind of confused
then there's other thing where like you
blunder a queen but then the queen
is reborn when you promote a pawn but i
don't know if that's also
reincarnation or if it's um
just pawn promotion i don't know
uh do we do it
night
reincarnated oh resurrection is another
i like the word resurrection
it actually sounds pretty nice
yeah you got to make an uh a bird emote
and then a polar bear emotes
so when you play f4 the people can spam
bird and then when you actually
complete your polar bear setup people
can spam the polar bear
yeah i'll have it ready once i have more
emote slots i'll just add it
yeah oh people have to sub to you to
enable the more slots let's do pause
more slots
i need um partners so oh
okay so people just have to view your
channel
right yeah i guess i guess
oh yeah take your time
yeah don't rush me think
my bad
oh is this it so
it's it's weird because i had considered
that idea a few moves ago and i forgot
about it
i was thinking of a completely different
pawn move but i like that
i like this move okay this is
usually what you do like with this
general setup yeah
so what are what are the requirements
for twitch partner
do you know so i think 75 like
consistent viewers is what they're
looking for uh like on average
gotcha let's do
let's do pawn again uh
hmm
a little bit concerned wait let me see
wait i don't have to be concerned i'm
giving you the same treatment you gave
me in the last game i'm just
continually saying pawn i guess first it
started with
knight yeah night moves were there in a
row
oh actually so there were five night
moves in a row
from move 7 to 11. now we
we're in two pawn moves in a row so far
let's do pawn again
okay yeah that's my battle cry
wait okay
oh opponent didn't uh didn't see the
material let's do pawn again
yeah it sounded like a blunder cry
sound like a blunder cry
okay i'm thinking
we have a lot of pawns out there
you can never have too many pawns may or
may not have overextended
okay well since we're this far
yeah yolo basically okay
okay awkward silence but i think it was
fine
i mean what else i mean i i think this
is like the
like one of the main plans in the polar
bear
like you have to hunt for food at some
point
is this going where i think it's going i
mean have you seen those like netflix
documentaries
like they they follow the polar bears
through like the the seasons and
okay never mind let me focus uh let's do
pawn again
wow this is our fifth pawn move in a row
oh wow it's another raid it's it's
varicomian
what's a var okay i'm thinking
pawns but like but like
my options are so limited
well that's maybe a good thing then you
have less decisions to make
you do that yeah shout out to var
who i streamed with other day me stream
with you too
[Music]
hope you had a good stream i'm really
scared
don't be scared the best way to overcome
fear is to pretend
to not be afraid
i think you think okay
okay
oh var just had a sub symbol
symbols are rough slimes are not easy
yeah have you ever like tried to
give one or stream one yes it's so much
multitasking
not not a pleasant experience no no
it takes a lot like a lot more
concentration
upon i think i'll just say pawn for the
rest of the game until you meet
or until we run out of pawns pawn
oh var played 17 words
the other day
okay it might be time to move something
that's not a pawn
hmm
actually pawn
someone clipping oh my god
this will be one long clip of pawn pom
pom pom pom
if this if this goes on youtube the
youtube video will just be pom pom pom
pom pom until i run out of the
whatever the character limit is oh
except yeah are there any
i think we have to do something else i
just realized our opponent's rating is
higher than
than normal yeah let's do bishop
oh do you know this person yeah oliver
prescott
yeah he's a vip on my channel and he
always beats you up
yeah he's younger than me but he beats
me up ah so this is a perfect time to
get revenge
maybe perhaps
[Music]
it's tricky this night is slightly
irritating
let's do
let's do rook
uh
i'm i don't compute but oh he's giving
me time how generous wow
oh that's so generous whenever your
opponent gives you time you should
not be nice back yeah exactly
sometimes they flag him but okay rook
i don't understand what you want me to
do with this rook
there's four legal rook moves okay
but that was not a good work decision
that was it honestly i don't know when i
initially said rook i was thinking of a
move that was a blunder
yeah rook b1923 right yeah but i i think
um i approve of your your choice
interesting
let's do
let's do rook again
it should be fun
should be fun i'm getting a question oh
let's do pawn
interesting question asking why we
didn't play h6
but that might be a question for you
when i kept saying pawn
and you didn't uh you didn't play h6 i
thought h6 would just kill
like kill our counterplay yeah no i i
would agree with that yeah
sometimes it looks it looks aesthetic
because we we control even more space
but yeah it kept on saying pawn i was
like i'm i don't want to take on g6 yet
i don't want to play h6
so and d4 is a common idea in the bird
and people were screaming at me so
ah okay yeah usually it's more valuable
to like
eventually open the h file rather than
keep it closed
even though sometimes alpha zero would
beg to differ alpha zero is known for
playing h6
but always depends on the position
it's nice you have a time advantage
moving quickly is paying off and his
generosity is he's also paying off yes
he oh someone just subbed sanghihi
but i realized you probably didn't hear
that so it is
i think it incognito subbing for two
months
uh oh
yeah it's actually not easy to
to crack the position
let's do man
let's do pawn are you thinking what i'm
thinking
i hope
okay and i just realized you can't see
my arrows but chad can see my arrows
yeah i can't okay let's do
let's do bishop
i don't know if our opponent is giving
us more time so
let's do rook
do
rook again
and now pawn
okay just gotta play quick on instinct
oliver says he'll give us more time do
queen
i don't know if we can trust the
opponent
but maybe we can he's been nice to us in
the past
yeah he gave us time he delivered oh wow
wow uh let's do queen
okay and game time um oh i feel i feel
time pressured but i just realized we
have more time
okay oh it's equal material
let's do
let's do bishop
[Music]
go with bishop again
now knight
oh yeah go it's a little rough wow
wait does it work oh it might work
or does it that's it oh no
uh let's do
king wow he gave us some two minutes
no white's clock has been set to two
minutes there was some divine
intervention here
wow so generous let's
be grateful and um i think
yeah there was a chance to call him
admin watching my stream
oh that's nice oh haha
uh let's do let's do rook
this is actually really interesting
oliver is like what about my time
this is why you have to be friendly to
the admins
okay uh rook
young
another tasty pawn okay
rook i think this end game favors king
favors the bishops though um
[Music]
you have to think happy thoughts king
oh pushy pawn is back with bits saying
push me baby push push
push uh king
so thankful our pawns are on dark
squares right now
knight again with the gratitude
wait oh oh opponents being
kind of annoying oh wow that was a good
move
wow can we
i'm looking for tricks
okay let's do uh pawn
this is entertaining wait did someone
raid i don't know if i realized
oh wow it's it's nemo chi u
aka with a raid wow so many people are
raining
thanks i didn't even realize that this
game has been so intense
shout out to nemo thanks so much let me
add you to this follow
aka nemsco uh
oh uh oh it's gonna get sharp
let's do pawn
knight
ah good move we have to do
process of elimination we have to do
king yeah
i don't know if i'm going the wrong
direction
yeah there's not too many directions to
go when you're on the close to the edge
ooh okay but now
oh it's complicated you're gonna have to
do
king again
okay now knight okay i'm thinking about
which square to put my knight on
i'm not sure if it matters
let's do let's do knight again
okay now the question oh it's a critical
moment
all right let's do king okay
king all right okay
i think we got lucky to escape
pawn wait that's a king
i mean okay this is pawn
wow what a game damn that was crazy game
yeah gg to the opponent i think we had
chances i don't know though do you want
to take a look at it yeah let's take a
look do you do your
announcement sport thing yeah my
analysis board
magic also for everyone just joining uh
welcome
this is chess we're doing something
called hand and brain
where one of us says the name of a piece
other
person has to make the move of that
piece it's called hand and brain
i think i just said that but this is uh
this is can i point i can point up so
this uh is kimilou
18 on twitch people can click the link
in the chat and follow her
a very active streamer on chess.com
and so far we're undefeated in hand and
brain
oh this is our first draw so
oh i see you you sent me the invite
um yeah so this was like a bird opening
almost turned polar bear so a lot of
people will play
like when they play d5 they'll play this
and then this is
probably a more traditional like polar
bear that i'm i'm familiar with
uh where you you use your bishop your
pawn and knight can to
control the key sign of squares
but what black played was interesting
and then probably knight d2 so yeah
when i when i said knight i was going
for this move
i think taking on c6 is fine but um
usually it's not a problem if black does
take we're we're happy to get this pawn
here
so we can follow up with d4 and like
here we'll have some nice
uh nice space
so um but we got this position
i like the kind of spirit of the play i
said pawn here i was expecting b3
just like the slow kind of methodical
development
but you just went all out yeah why did i
just not consider that
pretty weird uh
i mean you you were probably just
focused on attacking which
i mean that's the point of the setup
so if we keep going because they kept
not saying
yeah i was waiting for b3 bishop bishop
b2
but you were focused on attacking on the
king's side
yeah i know d4 is usually not the best
move like i i'm not that
you know oblivious but it's just d4 it's
usually a common idea in the bird but i
guess yeah
so actually so when i said pawn here i
think you have to play d4
to defend the knights we were fortunate
black didn't take because then we we
just our center kind of
dissolves yeah um
but uh
yeah this is a cool position because we
had like this huge kingside space
our king was a bit naked but it's hard
for black to attack us
and then there was like a nagging
question
from chat why why we don't play h6 here
and for newer players sometimes it's
harder to understand that um
like this this actually hurts less more
than it helps us
that can even play this and then we
can't actually crack the structure
anymore um so it's good to leave
the tension yeah i was going for takes i
mean there's other options
but um if we go forward
things got messy yeah from zero to 60.
yeah yeah a lot of moves you played were
my choices like b3 was good
e3 was good this is all i think we were
on the same wave
wavelength all through this
and then i'll admit i did i forgot about
this move
when i played knight g4 i only
considered rook takes e3
thinking that we can take with knight
and not not get our rook pins
uh when you said night i was like that's
like the only
safe square but not really yeah i'm
realizing
it's actually kind of difficult because
black's threatening this move
or k3 after which
like we can't effectively defend the a
pawn because our rook would be still
tied down to the bishop
so we won't have rook h2
um and currently like our bishops pinned
and our books tied down so it's not easy
to find a move here
and we were super low on time
so we could have tried king
i could have said king but again rook a3
and we can't defend this pawn
about king f1 king f1
but still king f1 there would be um rook
a3
uh yeah so
what ended up happening was interesting
because we we lost a pawn but we got a
lot of compensation
uh with the dark square control okay
and we got the pawn back
then yeah and then you you you made the
con i think it was just kind of a
like reflexive comment saying the bishop
is better than the knight
but the bishop can't really touch our
our structure
and black can never make progress
despite having a majority
with this um so i think if anyone was
playing for a win here it's white
with a good grip on the king side and
the outside passer
um but it was a tricky position because
it still requires some accuracy and you
went for like the very intuitive plan
of king b4 and like marching the pawn
unfortunately allowed black counter play
with the king coming in
should have kept the king on d4 yeah i
was thinking d4
i'm not sure if we can make progress
like if black just waits the question is
what do we do
um but there might be some opportunity
yeah we want to like come into these
squares we have to somehow like maneuver
our knight
to chase the king away and maybe it's
possible like maybe we can start with
knight c
knight 95 hit the pawn
if the bishop defends then we have
knight c4 and the king's coming in
and we can probably do the same thing
like again
like dance around the night or at this
point
um we can use the knight to help the
pawn advance
where we can play knight b2 and then
start pushing the pawn
and if the king ever tries to catch the
pawn then our king comes in
so i think it's winning it just requires
a lot of precision
and sometimes requires more time to
uh that i guess we kept getting more
time but
it always felt like we were under time
pressure yeah
um i mean what happened the game was
still really interesting like this pawn
race
and i was thinking like if we could just
get our pawn to a6 and a7
there's more chances but this was a good
move
at this point yeah and this is an
advantage of bishop overnight in the end
game it's a long distance piece
or long range piece so it helps defend
against
the pawn promoting and also helps black
uh
with promoting the e-pawn actually kind
of got in the way in this
in this case yeah and then
yeah i think we had to move our king
here if we move the knight then the
bishop
comes away and the pawn runs
that was a really good game though oh
good job oliver you've made a lasting
impression
yeah i think thanks to the opponent uh
yeah oliver oliver prescott
um i might end up putting this game on
my youtube channel
just just to like have the title of pawn
pon pon
so this goes on youtube i will uh i'll
leave links in the video description
to kimmy's channel people can check her
out uh
on twitch do you have a youtube channel
too or uh no
no okay so just just on twitch for the
time being
um and people on youtube if the video
ends here i'll see you in the future